this patient do can have symptoms that
is a tardas raising heart palpitation
very often chronic fatic syndrome
myalgic analitis symptoms of orthostatic
intolerance you not tolerant to staining
up so does that mean that they start to
have an exacerbation in symptoms
frequent heart beats patient feel as
palpitation dizziness lie headedness
sometimes giddiness so they feel like
they have the Jitters so and the cold
feet cold hands when they lie down they
have relief of the symptoms I want to
mention we're talking about Parts when
it's increas in heart rate but there is
also hypotension low blood pressure when
patient standing up the blood pressure
dropping this is
NSU prepare to dominate